U.S forces and their NATO allies are
conducting their own military drills
this week not that far from Ukraine
Chris lippsay went aboard a U.S Navy
warship and got an exclusive look at an
elaborate show of force in the
Mediterranean Sea
we fly at dawn from the southern coast
of Italy to join the USS George H.W bush
aircraft carrier a floating mountain of
muscle flexing with more than 80 Allied
aircraft in international waters for
NATO training
foreign
against the backdrop of Vladimir Putin's
repeated threats to fire nuclear weapons
the Secretary General of NATO Has Come
Aboard with a warning there will be
severe consequences it will be
absolutely wrong if I went into the
exact way we will react but Russia knows
that there will be severe consequences
and we are Vigilant and ready to
reactive something bad happens that's
something bad could be a dirty bomb an
explosive loaded with radioactive
material Russia now claims that Ukraine
wants to use one on the battlefield
is Russia laying the groundwork for a
potential false flag attack of its own
we have seen before that Russia has
accused others for doing what they
intend to do themselves so therefore we
are sending a strong message to Moscow
that they should not try to use a false
pretext
as an excuse for escalation of the war
in Ukraine for now NATO says its best
weapon is overwhelming deterrence with a
heart-thumping display of Firepower from
fighter jets and helicopters to
unparalleled surveillance with tensions
in the region at a fever pitch this may
only be combat training but if called
upon these Fighters say they're ready to
strike
to defend the alliance never to provoke
Russia they insist you're the Secretary
General of NATO aboard a U.S aircraft
carrier are you poking the bear we don't
seek conflict with Russia but of course
when we see more threats when we see a
more dangerous world it's even more
important that we send the clear message
to any potential adversary that we are
there to defend all allies because
that's the best way to prevent an attack
and preserve peace
and these are NATO's only exercises in
the region it's currently conducting
nuclear weapons training elsewhere in
Europe now these are yearly events but
given the backdrop of the war in Ukraine
and now the fears of a dirty bomb NATO
says its focus has never been sharper
Tony
yeah they don't want to be ready but
they have to be ready Chris lives say
for us in Italy Chris thank you very
much